what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we just learned a great deal about
what is going to happen as far as the
story arc for Doctor Strange goes with
Dr Strange three we also have some
awesome news about Miss Marvel season 2
and how she's going to fit into the
overall MCU after the Marvels now Doctor
Strange is going to be an extremely
important character moving forward in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe for the
Multiverse Saga especially when it comes
to actually wrapping things up in
Avengers Secret Wars we know that the
Multiverse is kind of going to be thrown
into chaos relatively soon with Deadpool
3 and Doctor Strange 3 and the King
Dynasty and ultimately we know that
doctor strange is going to be somewhat
at the heart of it all he's already
caused one incursion and his variants
seem to be causing other incursions to
happen and now there's going to be a big
multiversal group searching for him in
Doctor Strange 3 and it looks like
according to what we've learned Doctor
Strange is going to be exploring more of
his dark side in the future of the MCU
and Doctor Strange 3 secret Wars Etc
something that Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness hinted at is that
doctor strange is kind of a threat to
the Multiverse this is what Mr Fantastic
of the Fantastic Four and the Illuminati
stated to doctor strange but what's
really interesting about this scene
which is going to come into play in
Doctor Strange 3 that we've recently
heard about is that Mr Fantastic does
not specifically say that the biggest
threat to the Multiverse is you he
doesn't specifically blame the one
doctor strange but he simply says the
biggest threat to the Multiverse is Dr
Strange we appreciate your concern
Stephen but it's not the Scarlet Witch
that we fear from our experience the
greatest danger to the Multiverse it
turns out is Doctor Strange
but you're Dr Strange Earth's Mightiest
Hero who died defeating Thanos we should
tell him the truth so he was not talking
about a specific doctor strange he was
not talking about our main Universe
Doctor Strange he was talking about
Doctor Strange In general referring to
just all of the Doctor Strange variants
that are out there this is something
that is going to be explored in Doctor
Strange 3 a group called The Black
priests are going to be searching for
Doctor Strange because he seemingly is
causing incursions him and his variants
and they are a problem to the Multiverse
of course alongside King the Conqueror
which they're also going to discuss and
talk about and address now recently we
learned a lot more about Dr Strange and
his dark side thanks to the art of
Marvel Studios is Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness art book where we
learn more about the character from
director Sam Raimi in talking about
Doctor Strange he States he's a good
person but he's got his own
psychological problems he sometimes can
be a little selfish a little arrogant
proud out this prevents him from being
some Flawless good guy and he wrestles
with his dark side and he delves into
the supernatural in a way that some
other magicians who are fighting for
good think is immoral now we know that
doctor strange has a dark side we've
known that since the very first Doctor
Strange he's broken the rules he's tried
to do things his own way he's ignored
what other people who are more
experienced than him have told him and
we've seen it not work out for him in a
lot of different circumstances between
Doctor Strange One Avengers Infinity War
Dr Strange and the Multiverse of Madness
and what we've heard about the other
variants of Doctor Strange causing
incursions and dreamwalking this is all
due to everything that Sam Raimi
mentioned his arrogance and his dark
side but he goes on to tell us even more
he States therein lies a great conflict
with the character I find him to be a
character at war with himself which we
all are and so he's very relatable in
that way even though he's a superhero we
find Doctor Strange at the beginning of
Multiverse Madness as someone one who
was not only passed through the Mastery
of magic but who's now dealing with the
results of a life spent devoted to one's
craft at the extreme of his personal
life and I would argue that it would be
at the extreme of the Multiverse Doctor
Strange did some things that he thought
were going to be for the best and
thought that probably were the only way
to defeat the Scarlet Witch and save his
current universe but that had
repercussions for the entire Multiverse
and we learned that in the post-credits
scene when Cleo showed up and that
post-credit scene wasn't all it was made
out to be but we'll break that down in
just a bit Dr Strange 3 is going to
further explore Doctor Strange's dark
side because when a group of people
multiversal team shows up and says hey
you're the problem for the Multiverse we
know that doctor strange isn't probably
going to agree right away especially
when he learns about Kang the Conqueror
when he finds out there's a True Villain
out there he's probably going to say hey
it's not me it's him so whatever I'm
doing isn't the problem it's Kang and
his variants that are the problem
according to Multiverse of Madness
writer Michael Waldron embracing the
darkness and Doctor Strange's dark side
was what Multiverse of Madness was about
this will continue into Doctor Strange 3
because remember the Multiverse is going
to fall apart they're not going to fix
that in Doctor Strange 3. that's not
going to be fixed until Secret Wars and
even then it might not even be fixed we
are getting a soft reboot after that
movie so maybe it's not fixed maybe they
continue on with only a few universes or
maybe just one new fused main universe
that consists of multiple universes put
together so Doctor Strange 3 is going to
explore that concept of Doctor Strange
being the problem and kind of the root
problem with the exception of King of
the Multiverse kind of falling apart due
to incursions he's cost a few already
and there was already an extremely
powerful group that knew that he was the
core problem and now we have a
multiversal group called The Black
priest which Clea is a part of seeking
out Doctor Strange not necessarily to
get his help to fix an incursion that he
caused but to stop him this will be a
big premise of Doctor Strange 3. we'll
talk about that in just a bit but first
big thank you to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video many of you may
know that I personally use hellofresh
and I love it it makes cooking fun easy
and it's affordable and that's why it's
America's number one meal kit delivered
straight to your door and you might not
know that they actually have seasonal
recipes right now since it's summer they
have their new fresh and fit summer menu
so if you're trying to get that beach
bud but you're also trying to eat really
great tasting food it's perfect for you
right now it's peak time for summer
produce and hellofresh make sure you get
all the best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than seven days for Quality
you can taste if you are trying to
impress your friends this summer by
doing some cooking for them hellofresh
makes it super simple they give you all
of the ingredients and tell you exactly
how to make each meal and the best part
is right now you can go to
hellofresh.com 50 Cosmic and use code 50
Cosmic for 50 off plus 15 off the next
two months that's hellofresh.com 50
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50 off
plus 15 off the next two months
now in Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness we saw four main variants of
doctor strange and three of which caused
incursions our main Doctor Strange
obviously caused an incursion this was
made clear by CLIA obviously the 838
variant of Doctor Strange caused one as
well they made that very clear and the
one that we met at the end of the movie
had clearly caused an incursion as he
was still living on a world that had
endured an incursion in fact he was the
only one left and the doctor strange
that we saw in the very beginning of the
movie We're not really sure if he caused
an incursion or not but we do know that
he did try to kill America Chavez so
that dark side of Doctor Strange was
definitely explored there so we can kind
of see the pattern of Doctor Strange not
necessarily being so good so CLIA is
seeking Doctor Strange now she meets him
and tells him that he caused an
incursion and that he's going to help
fix it and that might be true but we
also know that CLIA is a part of the
multiversal group The Black priests and
essentially they are trying to stop the
Multiverse from exploding and being
destroyed now in the comics Doctor
Strange is actually a part of the black
priest he's actually their leader
obviously that's a very different route
in the movies now unless he ends up
becoming the leader but as of right now
the black priests have an issue with Dr
Strange because like we've mentioned it
does seem like he is at kind of the
center of the Multiverse kind of
collapsing now obviously Kang is also a
huge problem but there can be more than
one problem for the Multiverse so Doctor
Strange is going to kind of have to come
to terms with he may be an issue to the
Multiverse and he's got to fix that this
is what we're thinking could possibly be
happening in Doctor Strange 3 based off
of what we've heard from multiple
insiders up to this point we've also
heard recently as I mentioned in the
beginning that a Miss Marvel season 2 is
in development it's in the works right
now or I should say at least it was
before the strikes happen but according
to The Insider my time to shine hello
Miss Marvel season 2 is in the works she
stated this by replying to a tweet that
says you can only pick one a solo Kate
Bishop show or a Miss Marvel series 2 in
which she replied a solo Cape Bishop
series because Miss Marvel season 2 is
already in the works this comes as
little to no surprise we knew that she
was going to be a major character moving
forward especially because in the finale
of The Show for season one we discovered
that Kamala Khan is actually a mutant
and obviously there's a big future for
the MCU with mutants and the X-Men now
we're not sure when Miss Marvel season 2
is going to occur we do know that the
Bengal that she has is probably Kang
technology this is going to be further
explored in the Marvels and I'm sure
she's going to have a decent role in
Avengers Secret Wars we also know that
she's going to be a part of the Young
Avengers team and is actually going to
be one of the people who founds the
Young Avengers she'll be a founding
member so she's going to be extremely
important for the MCU and I wouldn't be
surprised if she still shows up after
Avengers Secret Wars and makes it into
phase seven and what we are calling the
mutant Saga after all she is a mutant
Marvel Studios made that very very clear
so we're not sure when season 2 was
coming before or after Secret Wars but
that is exciting news nonetheless so let
us know your thoughts about all of this
in the comments down below about Doctor
Strange 3 and Miss Marvel season 2. also
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
don't forget to like the video and if
you subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items we pick one winner at the end of
each month and the winner gets to pick
one item you can also find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof